Alex Bennett was born in Christ Church
New Zealand in
1970 he spent a year in Japan as part of
a high school Exchange program where he
first experienced Kendo leading to a
lifetime of dedication to this art
returning to Japan for graduate work he
received a PhD in human and
Environmental Studies from Kyoto
University in 2001 he subsequently
received a PhD in Japanese Philosophy
from the University of Canterbury in
2012 he has worked worked at the
international Research Center for
Japanese studies and the department of
Japanese studies at Teo University and
is currently a professor in the division
of international Affairs at Kanai
University Alex is also a prolific
writer on Japanese history and culture
in both English and Japanese over the
past few years his books have
fundamentally changed the way people
look at Japanese martial arts he also
founded and serves as editor and chief
of Kendo world the world's only English
language anguage Journal dedicated to
Kendo he is a seventh Dan Kendo Koshi
and holds High ranks in a number of
other
budo so we gathered here today to
celebrate the memory of D drer could you
tell us a bit about how he influenced
your work and perhaps also your life in
Japan well obviously I don't have a
direct relationship with dondrea he's
before my time um but uh like many uh u
martial arts enthusiasts around the
world um their introduction into the
theory uh of uh traditional Japanese
martial arts modern martial arts really
comes from uh the blueprint that Don
dragga
supplied uh is and he was able to convey
uh nuances about the culture which
Japanese people have a lot of trouble
conveying and he really sort of set the
tone for later generations of people
like myself who have dedicated um uh
lives to not only practicing but also
researching studying the martial arts so
without the work that drga uh did um you
know we would have
nothing uh to sort of build our
experiences on um unless of course you
speak really good Japanese and you live
in Japan for a long time which pretty
much counts uh most people in the world
out so he provided an incredible Service
uh not only to to um non Japanese uh
martial or Bud enthusiasts but also to
Japan um as well and that's something
that Japanese people don't
realize when dealing with the
groundbreaking works of pioneers it's
always easy to pick the holes and
inaccuracies or the misunderstandings in
their writings how will you think that
the initial writings of Drager stand
today to of course the much much larger
amount of knowledge that is available to
anyone um of course but that's uh you
know the fact that he was writing uh his
work in the you know 60s and'
70s um of course it's going to be dated
to a certain extent because you know um
budor research has come a long way uh in
the world but also in Japan as well um
so of course there's going to be areas
that are dated uh but that is not to say
um that the work is still incredibly
reliable it is kind of like still very
much broadly speaking the basis which
everybody um works from I mean if you
write an article or a thesis or
something you know in English about uh
something to do with Buddha culture um
if you don't have dondrea referenced you
know in your bibliography then nobody
takes it seriously because it means you
haven't done your work um but
interestingly I think dragga uh what is
a couple of things which
he uh still stands out and even you know
the the the researchers based in Japan
have a lot to learn of him one is the
work that he did in comparative martial
culture uh the Japanese researchers of
of budo uh tend to have a habit of just
looking at what they do and it's very uh
you know they don't like to look outside
they very rarely compare
uh the Japanese Bud bujutsu experience
with similar cultures around the world
Don Drager did that right from the start
and so in that sense he's he's still a
Pioneer um the other thing which uh I
think um is really important uh which
I'll probably talk about a little bit
today is he came up with uh
classifications um of uh
martial martial arts and civil martial
arts uh in other words he categorized
them as buits and Bud and further
categorized them into classical bujutsu
classical budh modern bujutsu modern
budh just to clarify here um the
difference between bujutsu and budo is
not something that is actually
necessarily present in Japanese writings
is it yeah no see this this is a really
interesting thing um Japan has a real
problem with identifying constructs of
what uh the various um uh kinds or
motivations of of Bud existed and and
what they've done generally is they
divided it into two kodor anything that
was before Magi and gai Bud anything
that's after Mii and K is always called
bujutu
or or kobor kodu and what dragga
identified you know um quite succinctly
was that even within the what is
generally referred to as bujutsu or
kodor there are many uh variations of
that and and in the modern era as well
there are also many variations and he
actually categorized those the problem
is he used the word bujutsu and budo um
which are used in a different way in
Japan and so there's a little bit of
confusion there but he did uh provide
some really interesting categorizations
which uh which are really needed in
Japan too um to sort of
uh because of how um IM my I'm trying to
think of the word in English what's I my
uh ambiguous sort of groupings that
they've got um there's a lot of
contradictions and and people's
understanding and often the reality and
the history sort of don't quite match up
and Drago he really did a good job at
matching that up so you can pick holes
in it because there are always
exceptions to the rule but essentially
provided a uh F of the groundwork which
I think now um has to be um looked at
once again and uh the fact that we're
holding a a Sy Symposium of this nature
in Japan uh and we had another one
yesterday with the Japanese Academy of
Bud which is where all the Japanese um
researchers of Bud gather and uh it um
interestingly uh gave them some uh of
course they're going to pick holes in
certain things but it also got them
thinking it's like wow gee we've gone
all this time without really cleaning
this mess up and he had already done
that um so his his
work I could I would say is becoming
even more pertinent now um many years
after his death and and that's why we're
revisiting it so dondrea and migration
of the spirit of Buu culture heresy heay
or here to stay um I will be talking
about my own experiences more than
anything and I understand that
everybody's different everybody's
experiences are different um and uh when
I talk about bud or I talk about Kendall
I don't uh pretend to represent that
just just my experiences to date so with
that disclaimer out the way let's have a
look
at Concepts in fact uh uh previous two
speakers uh chip and Lam have already
gone into this and uh
it's I think really drager's
Legacy
uh in terms of his the the constructs
that he
created um uh to well categorize the
various uh kinds of Bud and motivations
and so forth
uh has largely been ignored in
Japan and the more I look at it and the
more research I do from completely
different angles the more profound I'm
starting to uh to see his ideas were and
um let's just start by the official
concept yes indeed um Bud the martial
ways of Japan have their Origins and the
traditions of Bushido the way of the
warrior budo is a Time moded form of
physical culture comprising of Jud
Kendo practitioners study the skills uh
while striving to unify mind technique
and body develop his or her character
enhance their sense of morality and to
cultivate a respectful and courteous
demeanor
practiced steadfastly uh these admirable
traits become intrinsic to the character
of the practitioner the B Arts serve as
a path to self-perfection this elevation
of the human spirit will contribute to
their social prosperity and Harmony and
ultimately benefit the people of the
world okay so this is officially what
budall is um this was uh this philosophy
of Bud was in Japanese it's called Bud
it was established uh by the Japanese
Bud
Association uh well it's problem
problematic on many many different
fronts it serves a purpose and I'm not
here to criticize this but I think it
demonstrates uh some inherent problems
in the way that Buddha was perceived and
promoted in Japan and by virtue of that
everywhere else around the world um for
example uh where do I start
right well let's have a look at these
Bud first of all Judo created 1882 by
Koro okay great Kendo Kudo Sumo right
karate well it's not really Japanese is
it um aido uh well it's pretty much a
post-war thing really uh
shingo Nagi Nat and J Kendall etc etc so
we we something doesn't when you know
the history you know that something's
not right with this if you don't know
the history uh then it's oh really n
okay great um so on the surface I think
this is fine but this really represents
some uh deeply entrenched conceptual
misunderstandings that exist in
Japan okay the so-called home of Budd
culture one other thing which is I think
is really important here it doesn't even
mention at all uh Kobo or
k um and that quite simply is because
it's treated as completely
separate a completely different
thing but uh as we've heard from our
previous speakers and from my own
personal experience training in koru and
gendai budo uh for around about 30 years
um I think of them as essentially the
same and very complimentary as well um I
think it's a
glaring problem uh that kobudo and budo
in Japan are treated essentially as two
different
things let's have a look at uh Don
drager's uh constructs which um uh chip
and Liam have already talked about but
it's good to go back because really
they're quite
remarkable um chip introduced uh in his
presentation uh Dr this is from a from
Electra I believe is it right so martial
competitive systems combative systems
are those whose primary intended design
and function aimed at application to the
military Battlefield and he's divided
that into classical bitsu and modern
bitsu now when we normally think of
budgets we think of stuff that was
around before the Magi period what drag
is uh saying here as well no no there's
bujutsu in our period as well TSU what
the police do for example you know that
was created in the 20th century um civil
combative systems or pleum um systems
are those whose primary intended design
and function are aimed at civilian-based
outcomes okay becoming a better person
through the vehicle of of Buddha and
again he divides these up into classical
Buddha and modern Budd now when we think
of Buddha today uh we think of gendai
Buddha as in all the stuff that was
created from after Cano Juro invented
his uh his um Judo um but classical Bud
uh again U many many
duha which we call kodu now or kodor
were created in the Tokugawa period
which uh saw no um military uh
application or
experience and so the purpose of those
were really uh well a kind of way of
honing the body and polishing the mind
and so on and so forth very similar to
the kind of things that we have seen in
the very first slide about the concept
of Budd
today um so he makes these distinctions
but broadly speaking budet are first
priority combat Follow by discipline
morals to make yourself combat effect of
Buddha morals discipline aesthetic form
so um just this is just to simplify
everything to bring it all back together
to where he was coming from classical
bujutsu medieval early modern time
Battlefield combat
soldiery H classical Budd medieval early
modern period civil martial arts modern
bujutsu mag onwards police Army Etc and
modern Buddha mag on Woods civil the
nine Buddha that were mentioned uh in
the philosophy of Budd and others that
aren't and that's another important
Point as well uh for example um my
university in Japan where I work is
Kanai University and Kanai university
has its own Buddha Believe It or Not uh
you've heard of Nong Kempo right Nong
Kempo was actually invented by um a
former student at Kanai University so
what makes Shing Kempo more
important or representative of a gendai
bud than nongo in fact I believe San
even went and studied a little bit of
Nong Kempo as well so there's a lot of
political wrangling that was going on
there as well so um I don't want to get
into that but the point is that as uh
well one of the big problems in Japan
today there's so many contradictions
that sort of aren't even questioned
anymore um but going back uh to what
Drager
um his classifications I think I came at
it from a completely different
perspective but essentially it all turns
out to be the same now I've given
everybody a print uh which uh is for
your reference and it's it's still a
work in progress um but I sort of
plotted uh the evolution if you like uh
of the marshal arts or martial culture
in Japan and the various Trends social
trends social historical Trends and so
for and I've used a word uh constantly
throughout
reinvention now everybody's heard of the
concept I I I imagine um that was made
famous by Hobs borne uh the invention of
tradition the invention of tradition is
it's well it's a little
bit uh every tradition of course it's
invented so what's new about that but
when when you hear invention of
tradition it's usually in reference to a
specific period of time in world history
particularly the 19th century or perhaps
early uh 20th century uh when modern
nation states were being created and in
order to uh formulate a specific
distinctive national identity they would
borrow uh things from the past and in
Japan's case Samurai culture became one
of those things that was very useful for
uh creating an identity that made the
Japanese distinct ined in the world
stage and so on and so forth but so when
we talk about modern oh sorry the
invention of tradition the time period
is almost
always um around about here
miji uh period not only in Japan but you
know everywhere around the world um but
if we look at the uh the Marshal culture
of Japan we see this constant
reinvention actually um
because the the
uh martial arts had to adapt or had to
be used to suit completely different
social situations even within the same
country and so it's a it's an ongoing
process so what I'm trying to get out
here uh in
Japan uh now the way that Buddha is
usually categorized as I said it's a
dichotomy um kodor and modern Bud um
obviously this is not enough because
even before the modern period there's
every every period every region almost
is different participation in the
martial arts took on different reasons
different meanings uh throughout history
so to lump it into two like that is very
simp simplistic
um to put it nicely so another
one of the problems though with drager's
constructs I don't think it's a problem
as such but uh in Japan it's largely
ignored or it is criticized because the
way in which he uses the word bud in
Buju is actually a little bit
different uh to the way it is used or
understood in Japan Bud as a word for
example um now when you hear bud you
think ah Judo Kendo karate etc etc but
um for most of the uh the words
existence um budo actually meant Bushido
it actually meant uh the warrior ethos
not martial arts as such um other
problems which sort of were mentioned
very briefly yesterday um when you think
about uh bitu being martial technique
therefore more combat oriented and Budd
being the modern uh uh reincarnation if
you like or reinvention into a into a
way for uh educational purposes well
that's broadly speaking sort of true in
Japan but there was a time in Japanese
history uh the 1930s in particular where
Buddha actually became very combat
oriented or at least it was it was
utilized for that purpose so the there's
there's a lot of confusion even in Japan
with how these words are used there is
no real consent
ensus
um so it's always been changing as I've
mentioned so lumping everything into old
and new as it is in Japan at the moment
is very problematic and it also ignores
what drag was pointing out that both are
or can be civil and both can be martial
actually as
well um another
problem is this in Japan
and you know fairly standard
international understanding is Bud is
actually in terms of its moral
significance Superior to
Jutsu okay so um D is more important or
uh more Humane perhaps than Jutsu well
Jutsu the word itself it has many
different translations you hear some
science you'll hear technique you'll
hear art and so forth but um again if we
if we refer to Drager as he rightly
pointed out even uh the so-called bujutu
had a very important moral or uh
self-cultivation aspect to it but this
sort of became it was a very simple I
guess you could call it a marketing Ploy
um I might get into trouble if I say I
definitely would not say this in the or
anything like that but because it's you
guys I will say it it was a marketing
Ploy by um Kano Nike
jiguro just do it baby and the reason
why he did that um was because uh he
wanted to make his style of jiujitsu his
duha of jiujitsu if you like something
that's distinct distinctive from
jiujitsu as it was commonly known at the
time had a very bad
reputation as being something practiced
or used by Ruffians and so no no no no
what I'm doing is far more profound it's
more about education of the human mind
and the body that's why I'm going to
call mind door um and J and so there's
old and this was this ball this Nike
ball was picked up by another fellow um
in the mid uh TAA period it's about 1919
I think it was Nishi and he was actually
the mayor of Tokyo at one stage but he
also became vice president of the
D which was kind of like the gatekeeper
for this burgeoning new martial
Traditions that were making the rounds
in Japan at the tune of the century and
uh he was also the became the uh the
president or the principal of the
Dan special school that was established
to train teachers who could go out into
the community throughout the country and
spread uh
Bud talk about that um so as it stands
today with the kudor and the bud
dichotomy what are the differences how
are the approaches different what what
is the the kind of the flavor of them
well first of all let's look at there's
there's a different kind of prejudice
involved um I've used the word
ethnocentrism here but in terms of
Buddha there's a belief in Japan that
obviously uh and there's a lot of Pride
attached to the fact that bud is
inherently inherently
Japanese uh
bud and I'm forgive me I I know I'm
generalizing here um but seeks uh
differentiation from non Japanese
athletic culture or Sports which for
some reason is a dirty word in Bud as if
Sports is in a culture as well um it is
promoted internationally as soft power
in the form of traditional Japanese
sport so here we have another
contradiction um
and uh it always
stresses um and to uh highlight it U
distinctiveness um the Paradox the
Paradox the
Kat Paradox of using techniques of
Destruction for personal cultivation so
that's that's um a description of Budd
in a nutshell that would be how I would
explain uh buddh what about codu well
it's similar the way it is interpreted
and the way it is uh organized in Japan
belief that codu is inherently Japanese
fine seeks differentiation from Buddha
that's Japanese Buddha and other
non-japanese martial culture it's
promoted sort of as soft power uh in the
form of intangible cultural
heritage okay and finally stresses the
Paradox of using techniques of
Destruction for personal cultivation so
that sort of thing sort of is this is
the same
right again how is Bud and Kor divided
in Japan um I've got up here what is Bud
which would translate into also what
isn't
kodor um and this is
really uh what the general consensus is
of how Buddha evolved into what it is
post
Magi um in order to make uh the
traditional kodor something that uh is
accessible to uh all Japanese people
because let's face it it is part of
their traditional
Heritage uh something that by virtue of
being born Japanese you have Samurai DNA
um and this is something that's very
important to that so in order to make it
accessible to children in the school
system uh obviously uh safety was an
issue we can't have kids killing each
other um
techniques uh and the facilities and
Equipment were uh well developed to
ensure that more people would be able to
participate they needed Fair criteria
for judging that means Shi uh rules and
uh and even uh examinations promotion
examinations for Dan Q Etc um it had to
be well I don't know if homogenized is
the right word
standardized um which required removal
of specific newa
identifiers okay because Dua were uh
always uh
rather um well antagonistic perhaps
traditionally speaking towards each
other um there was no well obviously it
required no particular official
religious affiliation um maybe Kinto
State Shinto was a kind of a strange uh
uh exception to that but uh open
participation it was no longer
officially the domain of samurai or Rich
uh um shamim uh everybody uh could and
was encouraged to participate um it
required a transparent and egalitarian
governing body as opposed to the Soul
Care System uh or other traditional
means of um passing on that knowledge
and also rational teaching methodology
for group instruction so these this is
generally how um gendai Bud the
evolution of gendai budo is explained uh
in Japan uh
today so this is General perception in
Japan uh which eventually makes its way
into the Big Wide World um bud and codu
if we compare them bud postm codu premi
bud is inclusive codu is
exclusive uh budo is combat Roots kod is
combat oriented
um budo is competition oriented kodu is
Kata oriented rational teaching content
versus Arcane teaching content
educationally oriented versus
educational potential aesthetic highly
aesthetic aesthetic highly aesthetic no
some Western influence in Bud uh no
Western influence in C uh the door Jutsu
thing and um I love this word thank you
chip agnostic okay so
competition uh versus k um so this is uh
whether you agree with this or not this
is what I perceive as sort of like the
general uh understanding of or the
Divide if you like between bud and kodor
in
Japan um I'm just going to come back to
that a little bit later on okay so now I
want to go into uh just briefly look at
uh well what I call Buddha
migration uh is it
heresy or is it is it heay well we all
know uh that it's not heay because
everybody's here uh for example bud I
often say
is probably Japan's most successful
cultural export yeah yeah yeah Sushi I
know um anim yeah yeah yeah yeah cool
cool cool cool but Bud has been around a
lot longer okay and we all know as well
that there are far more Budd
practitioners in total outside of Japan
than there are in
Japan uh if we look at the waves and
again this is a work in progress but
just generally speaking it sort of
starts Ed back as Liam mentioned before
early days mag period uh you introduced
some people uh westerners who came over
here um like FJ Norman um but uh they
were sort of an exception there were a
lot more Japanese who were going out of
Japan and settling in other countries
around the world so Japanese migration
colonialism um and particularly after
the Russia Japanese war this all
contribut Ed to um sporadic but very
healthy budha populations in certain
centers around the world and I've got a
newspaper this is
1905 uh this is from the ockland Star
newspaper which uh they pilfered from a
British newspaper because they always
used to get the British news and put it
in the newspapers in New Zealand this is
one of hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of articles that I just dug up
um and the Alexander turble liary in New
Zealand about martial arts Japanese
martial arts making their way to the
West this is fantastic I'll read it out
to you the Japanese art of jiujitsu or
self-defense has become the rage in
London and elderly ladies attired in
physical culture dress wrestle with each
other instead of going to the countless
massage establishments I'm not quite
sure what that means but
anyway spinsters living in lonely
suburbs are learning the art so that
they can tackle Hooligans in cases of
necessity where small Sky Terriers
afford little protection young men and
old men have put themselves in the hands
of Japanese professors and the result of
the boom has been an influx of little
yellow men into
London many of whom are very indifferent
teachers nothing changes there now there
are now over 40 schools of jiujitsu in
London and this is 1905 we're talking
about over 40 schools of Jiu-Jitsu in
London and the physical culture people
and those who run gymnasiums are doing
all they can to pour cold water on the
Japanese fad as being extremely
dangerous and Joint
dislocating so so much of this stuff out
there it's remarkable but it was quite a
phenomenon um so we can see that you
know from an early stage for various
reasons Bud well wasn't called bud at
all but martial arts uh were making a
real uh impact
um what else I got there ah
yes
wartime I can go back uh okay wartime uh
this the sort of focus
on uh the martial arts in the west well
it moved to as it did in Japan very
combat oriented and this is this is
actually really fascinating this uh is I
got this from the uh from University um
they have the
bow collection there and this was a
magazine I I think the Magazine's name
was
Illustrated
1944 okay and there's a special uh
section in there about how the RAF okay
that's the Royal Air Force um
was uh really getting into their Judo
right now Japan was at War
with
Britain they were they were enemies and
here we have it
1944 uh group of people in a dojo
dressed in Japanese attire doing the old
Japanese regy thing okay and
participating in Judo which is sort of
uh and by the way the uh the instructor
is Sergeant Chu okay I don't know if
anybody knows him but um I just thought
this is this is quite an incredible um
situation really isn't it when you when
you think about the hostility and the
the hatred that existed between um Japan
and and and other Allied uh countries at
the time but such was again the the the
Allure of Japanese martial
arts um get to the 1950s you find uh
well when GHQ um set up or the
occupation Force set up base here in in
Japan this was another time that sort of
uh introduced budor to a completely new
group of people and we see articles like
this is from the Far East News American
shown deadly power of karate hand combat
taught and okino and St so we'd get
teachers going out to the the bases and
and uh teaching um well in particular
karate and and Judo um I found this the
other day too um d drga right Marine
Judo expert coaches
aspirants uh with first Marine division
now this um the date I think was
1953 um I think I'm not quite sure
uh um if anybody has any idea but a
school of Japanese Judo is currently
operating behind the front lines of the
first Marine Division in
Korea taught by Marine Captain Don F
drer Milwaukee
Uh current Japanese Intercollegiate
champion and fourth degree black belt
holder the school has attracted wide
interest am among the
leathernecks I don't know what a
leatherneck is I sort of thought Turtles
were called leather necks but um in any
case Captain Drager who is vice chairman
of the US national aaou Judo committee
hauled 15 Japanese tat tatami mats over
to Korea for his students and they form
a practice ring for Judo aspirants on
the headquarters Battalion stage so
there was a photo there somewhere
obviously um we start looking uh going
further down into the
1970s um popular culture uh movies uh
and books which I'll talk about very
shortly uh again sort of inspired
another boom or were inspired perhaps by
um in particular karate Sho Ninjutsu of
course uh uh something that's virtually
unheard of in Japan funnily enough
became started become very popular
overseas and uh uh just a roundabout
this time a little bit before this is
another photo has anybody seen this
photo
before has anybody seen it you have
right nobody else how about um you
haven't this is actually I got this from
the all Japan Kendo Federation archives
and they didn't even know they had it um
but it's actually D drga um um
demonstrating
jordo uh in 1964 at the nion Budokan um
to
commemorate uh obviously the holding of
the Olympics in
Tokyo uh and also the first time that
Judah was to um become an an official
event they had a series of other budha
demonstrations and uh D is one of
the demonstrators I think this is quite
a rare rare
photograph um we get into the 1980s we
start talking about well the Eastern
boom you know
Zen uh and this Eastern holism type
thing iido Kudo became particularly
popular um sorry I'll I'll jump past
that where are we okay and a little bit
later on uh the bubble okay which is
about the time when I came to Japan uh
or a little bit towards the end of it
and so from the bubble of course we see
this massive uh in uh interest in things
Japanese and uh what makes Japanese
business Teck how did they
become the economic animals that they
are wow that must be samurai strategy
that's what it is and so there was a a a
whole lot of interest that was um
directed at understanding uh Japanese
Marshal culture Marshal history from a
completely different perspective
management or an economic perspective
and you start
seeing uh books like M Masashi G being
uh translated and to this day uh these
books um and other books like Bud
Shu and
haak and wait for it wait for it uh and
so forth these these books not martial
arts per se but sort of like seen as
being the the philosophical extension of
the martial arts and by virtue of that
not only by reading and understanding
this Samurai history and culture but
people also started participating with
more enthusiasm in the Arts
themselves you're
welcome okay if you're interested we're
not we're not supposed to Market things
here right so anyway moving
on um and so on and so forth up to up to
the uh present day the 2000s terrorism I
think uh sort of sparked another kind of
boom and this it's just it's just it
comes and Es and flows these waves of
dissemination and it's an ongoing thing
and what's interesting here is like um
the motivation the reasons why people
are doing uh Bud change outside of Japan
changes depending on the period I came
here I started as I said in the in the
mid to yeah mid 80s I guess you could
say mid to the late ' 80s um when I
teach uh International students at
University and they're interested in
martial arts it's not uh to do with the
samurai culture or the mindset or the uh
the economic sort of application that it
was when I started it was completely
it's completely about anyare all right
and it's it's you know just everything's
everything is is is always
changing um the
Budokan uh has been very
uh
active uh in
promoting uh Japanese martial culture uh
as a form of I guess you could say soft
soft power which I mentioned before
around the world uh to date we've had 30
actually I tell a lie 31 International
Buddha Seminars the first one who was
there at the first
one yeah right that's right
you guys caused so much
trouble you did you did um I was there I
was there I saw it I didn't understand
any of it but I saw it and just to
to reminisce I'm sure you'll remember it
was it was very tense the international
Bud seminar um and when it first when
they first had had it in
1989 uh the whole idea was to invite uh
Budd practitioners non-japanese Budd
practitioners uh to hear
lectures on uh various aspects of Buddha
culture the history the
philosophy um and also participate uh in
what they call TA budor where you might
be a Kendall practitioner but you've
always wanted to try kudor or you've
always wanted to try short in Kemp or
something so you get this opportunity to
train
and practice uh to try them out and it
was really really a lot of fun it was
really cool and it lasted for 30 years
um the very first one was interesting
because we had experts in the field the
bud Khan took the approach that well you
know we're going to teach these
foreigners about Bud because they really
don't understand it and we're going to
help them understand it and so you get
these uh cynical hology rocking up
asking very difficult
questions and to be honest I I I think
uh the professors were completely and
totally up for anything the problem was
with the interpreting I believe and a
lot of stuff was uh well it went off on
the wrong you know the points were
missed and because the points were
missed the people asking the questions
were getting a little bit frustrated
although they were too polite to ask in
Japanese themselves because we had
interpreters then you know and that
would mean that they would lose face
right um and so the questions were
getting completely different answers and
the tension built and it built over the
the couple of days that were there and
right at the
end everybody was all the SES were uh
the lecturers and and so they're all up
the front and they had this
session uh if you want to ask any
questions about bud
now's your time and it was a kind of a
nervous sort of nervous tension in in
the air again I I I didn't know anything
about what was going I was just sitting
there going wow what's going on here and
and right a guy called Greg really cool
dude um I I wonder what happened to him
uh he was a ninja right he practiced in
and he walked up to the
mic and he had his hat on and he had his
hands in his pockets and he was about to
ask one of the senses a question and
then
suddenly one of the Budan staff came up
and said backck it up and then all hell
broke loose because he was offended he'
been you know he' seen the tension and
and he thought that you know we was
showing great disrespect to the people
when you get this guy with dress like
this coming up and asking questions it's
like well this is just just too much for
him and he went
nuts you went absolutely nuts and it's
like
Whoa man you could cut the air with a
Shai I tell you it was pretty it was
pretty hardcore like oh Jesus what are
we going to do anyway interestingly the
last Budd seminar was held last year
they suddenly scrapped it for another
one
and they had the first International
budhha seminar for exchange students and
Embassy staff in March so that means
that everybody there uh for for the most
part were inexperienced in in martial
arts
right
and this is actually a
photo this is this is FEI okay Fe is
from Nigeria and he is a total dude man
he is really really cool but here you
have it okay uh from Nigeria with his
sunglasses his military cap and his
knuckle duster gloves on asking a
question uh this is actually actually
asking a question and The Bu stuff none
of them blinked an
eye at all and I I just
remembered poor old Greg 30 years ago
that almost started World three and
anyway FEI comes up here and does the
same thing and what my point here is wow
the Japanese have come a long way here
in fact
afterwards anyway
so Khan has been uh oh I'm going to run
out of time I really have to put this in
um anybody know this
guy Randy Channel yeah he completely
helped us all out because after this
went down and and the bhan staff went
crazy he put his hand up he just say
I've got a question that's been bugging
me for years and years and I I just hope
that one of the esteemed Sensei
professors can answer it for me I think
this is really important uh to Budd and
it can really help us understand a lot
everybody's going oh God what's Randy
going to do now what's he going to do
and he goes
can you please tell me how Bruce Lee
[Laughter]
died this is Randy now he's a tea Master
for Ur in kilor yeah so anyway so books
and videos are another thing uh like I
was involved with this book K in my life
uh which is the audiography of Kazo
hirok Kazu I put that in English the
books uh
involved in pretty much all of these
Buddha the martial ways of Japan um Sak
s ideology of the sword um which I uh
did the editorial supervision and of
course
UMES um book which was translated by
Daniel Lee so the buan really is doing a
lot to to try and get the word out there
if you like and they have BD delegations
that they send all around the world
every year I was involved with the uh
trip to Australia uh for one delegation
they take about 70 people Nal s was also
on one of them a few years ago uh the
budget that they spend on this to go
overseas uh do a demonstration for a
public demonstration and also usually go
to a Japanese school in the area to to
mingle with the children would take 70
people usually from the nine modern bud
and three k uh when I went to Australia
uh the bill for that for that one trip
was uh n May so that's close on a
million dollar right uh New Zealand
dolls so a lot of money goes into this
uh the bud Khan itself you know they're
host to International competitions and
so on and so forth actually this is a
photo from the first Bud seminar that's
me about to get squashed uh by Randy
Channel believe it or not
um another
thing that I should just you all know I
believe uh the the bud Charter that
first came out I think it was in the
late 1980s and the original Japanese
translation uh sorry English translation
of that was was somewhat uh skewed I
think um where like the underl section
of here however infatuation with mere
Technical Training and undue concern
with winning is a severe threat to the
essence of Buddha and the in the
inference was that since it's become
popular internationally it's starting to
go down hill so we got to go back and
work out what the spirit of Buddha is
and we got to PR we got to preserve this
natural heritage this National sorry
National Heritage of Japan
um I along with a a fellow called John
Rogers who I think is absolutely
magnificent scholar who unfortunately
died a few years ago go uh we're tasked
with retranslating this into something a
little bit more uh guing user friendly
and we sort of changed a few things
around it's just uh you know Finding
nuances um like some of the changes that
we made were to try and sort of move it
away from them since it's become
internationally popular things are going
downhill uh or uh let's not worry about
naal culture let's just preserve this
traditional culture because as all of
you guys here I'm sure myself included I
I've dedicated myself to the study of
budo not because I particularly want to
become a Japanese
person I just do it because I love it
and it helps me as a person so to take
away that kind of
uh again I got to be careful here but
that kind of cultural
imperialism sort of we sort of um we
made it a little bit more uh well less
provocative perhaps um but you know
again I don't want to criticize and this
this is article six from the from the
budo charter uh one the sixth article is
about well clearly maintains that
promoting Buddha people who promote
Buddha must maintain an open mind
International perspective and this is
actually really profound but it's not
really what's
happening it's exactly what d
drga uh did for us but he is largely
unknown in Japan he's largely unknown
and his contributions are largely
unknown if anybody uh he is the man
who
really not only for Japanese buddo but
his his approach was to to look at all
of the different martial cultures around
the world and compare them
and see if we can find some common
threads here which helps us understand
everything Humanity um and and many more
different ways rather than the inward
thinking that kind of
represents uh the Japanese Buddha uh
today um I'm going to I've got 10
minutes left and I've got a lot to get
through so I'm going to jump ahead just
um what I'm talking about this
International spread of Buddha um as I
said before I think that Budd is uh is
Japan's greatest cultural
export
and one another thing that's surprises
me is the surprise that many of my
Japanese colleagues and
Friends uh display when they realize how
incredibly far-reaching bud has become
and the various reasons that they do it
uh I've got a whole list of stuff here
why people start Bud outside of Japan
and in Japan as well it's the same sort
of thing but obviously I can't talk
about all of them but there's one in
particular one area in particular uh
that interests me um because my first um
uh research field was actually um
religious studies and religion is
something that religion and Buddha as a
religion in a way is is is an idea or or
something that that fascinates me
and um I'm just going to jump AC that I
just going to introduce just a very
short episode experience I had living in
Iran um when I say I lived in Iran I was
only there for about 6 months and that
was in 2004 and the reason I went over
there was to uh obviously a very um
uh devout Islamic country uh I wanted to
see the extent that Japanese martial
arts the influence that they have in in
in Iranian culture to my surprise when I
went over there uh discovered that um
the number one uh physical activity in
Iran is
soccer okay well that's no surprise but
number two collectively are the martial
arts and I thought that was really
really interesting I just like for
example this I was mainly in with the
with the Kendo people um but this is a
an Iranian niono handmade because you
can't just go down to the shop and buy
one obviously uh handmade and in fact
that blade it looks like your typical EI
um well it's not it was actually the sus
uh the spring suspension from a car that
was hammered out very sharp very
dangerous I don't trust those meis at
all but this is um what you know my my
uh friends over there were practicing
Eid do with um I did a little bit of
sightseeing while I was there as well
and I went and saw uh these Zoro estrian
um ruins uh Zoro estria um uh the
religion was uh preceded Islam in Iran
and so these are not taken care of this
is actually a burial
mound uh traditionally when people die
they would take the bodies and place it
on top and uh and return it to to Nature
sort of very shint sort of outlooking
away but you notice here there's some
graffiti okay there's a graffiti and
thought what what the hell was that I go
up there I go inside the thing and I
found more of graffiti do you know what
this
is heyi
yeah and I can't read this but my friend
tells me yeah King is the strongest
karate is what it says apparently
okay and I thought wow this is amazing
this photo is bizarre uh I didn't know
until afterwards um but when I uh my
friend was showing me around he said
okay today we'll go and we'll check out
some iido cool cool we go to this place
and there's a whole lot of guys standing
outside with big machine guns and he
said just shut up don't say a word we
don't want people people to real know
that you're a foreigner so I just just
of walked in and um walked through a few
corridors we found this place okay and
you can't see it here I really kicked
myself I'm not taking a photograph but
there were photographs of
AI okay next to him
was
and all lined up together it's like wow
this is amazing anyway I watched the the
aido practice and then I leave and then
my friend said to me do you know where
we've just been I said no he goes this
was the American
Embassy this is the American Embassy
okay so you all know of course what
happened in 1979 on Jimmy Carter's watch
uh the Teran University students stormed
the embassy and since then America has
hardly had any uh diplomatic relations
with uh with uh Iran but fortunately um
the old building is being put to much
more uh uh better use I think it's a
dojo now or part of it is the other part
of it is a museum that uh extols the
evil influence of Western imperialism so
that's another thing um but um talking
to the Iranian people I was in
retrospect je I'm surprised they let me
do this but I minute was allowed to take
a questionnaire about 500 people about
why they do martial arts and
and it was it was quite remarkable my
take on this was okay so budor has a
very strong moral
element and how does does it have any
how does it fit with the Islamic World
Outlook and the reason I chose this
example is because of the tragedy that
happened in my hometown in Christ Church
last week so it's to pay um respect uh
to our um uh Islamic friends as well um
there were many many different sort of
uh areas I could have introduced but
what what was fascinating for me was um
I can't read this of course but I had
somebody read it for me and go through
it all and really the over the overall
sort of uh consensus is that practicing
Budd whatever that is be It karate be it
Judo be it Kobo um to them serves as a
supplement for their
religion it's not in contest with it
it's not better it's not worth
by doing Budd
um you become a stronger person in mind
and body and therefore a better Muslim
and I thought this is absolutely
fascinating how something that was you
know born in Japan can can go pretty
much anywhere in the
world uh anywhere in the world and be
adapted and adopted uh to something that
can be useful or seen as being perceived
as being useful in the Civil martial
arts sense uh to the uh the social norms
of of that particular um Society or
culture um I'm going to finish off now
I've got 5 minutes and uh I just want
to uh go back to drga
Sensei you see uh for gendai bud at
least um all pretty much every of the
nine uh gendai bud have international
federations J kendor is a work in
progress but just uh
um we we will have something organized
very soon I think but if you look at the
years uh where these International
federations were formed this this
coincides with the other print that I've
given you um this is actually Tony cundy
uh sort of plotted this so I appreciate
uh what he's done here it sort of puts
things in
perspective um you can see where in
particular uh the 1970s 1980s where Budd
sort of became quite an international
phenomenon um
drager's Works were
instrumental his work was instrumental
and fundamental and helping create the
momentum and the Phil uh the
philosophical understanding of buddh
culture which allowed Japan to achieve
wide scale International dissemination I
think you could say you could say I'm
sure he would be horrified he would be
horrified if I sort of uh well if he if
if anybody suggested suggested this to
him when he was alive but there books in
a way for for westerners in particular
the Book of
Genesis in the prostatism of of Japanese
Buddha we didn't have anything like that
and the Japanese powers that be that
we're trying to promote the Buddha
there's always as there was in the first
Buddha seminar that we went to there's
always that linguistic barrier and that
that uh that incredible difficulty in
trying to express or v um
context um but dragga did all that for
us I think it's because of his work that
bud was able to become the international
phenomenon that it is today uh is it
here to stay I'm going to jump ahead cuz
I got three minutes
um just want to address one more thing
and I think this is really
important and uh Liam uh said uh Dawn
Drager was deeply concerned with the
codu would survive and if so in what
form uh to ensure their survival he
wanted to spread serious non-japanese
among the codu um and ship said very
early on Don draga told me that these
old traditions were and are vibrant
living entities not only are they worth
preserving saving uh but they have
significant vital lessons that are
applicable to the Fighting Man of
today's world it's exactly what uh um CH
introduced to us
before now un fortunately because of
this dichotomy that is Arisen uh kodor
versus Bud I think that both kodor kodu
if you like and gendo have some serious
fundamental problems I would give them a
d okay at the moment um problems with
codu dwindling numbers Dreadful Dreadful
technical level overall if you go and
see demonstrations it's like oh my God
are you serious okay uh disjointed
historical understand in deficient
comprehension of context depressing
political wrangling discrimination
abounds Dar of reliable information
disabled by dubious tradition or
traditions and doesn't respect modern
Buddha it's missing g g
g but what about bud bud okay dwindling
numbers in Japan at least deteriorating
technical level disjointed historical
understanding hello deficient
comprehension of context depressing
political wrangling discrimination of
bounds death of reliable information uh
disingenuous to tradition and doesn't
respect
codu
okay speaking from a Kendo perspective
but I think other budo are probably
similar what do we think of the kodu as
gendai Bud practitioners kodu was boring
it's too esoteric it's full of weirdos
and W to be
samurai codu doesn't have any point it's
traditional dancing codu will give me
bad habits codu won't help me whenn
competitions or past grades codu will
keep me away from already limited care
cor time codu smells of
pomposity
this okay well what about cod's
objection subjective objections Kendo is
not the real thing Kendo is merely a
sport Kendo is full of Meatheads Kendo
pisses on tradition Kendo is egocentric
Kendo is violent Kendo will keep me away
from already limited care time and Kendo
just smells okay am I wrong okay there's
prejudices out there guys right now as
somebody who now sort of feels
comfortable and been able to say this
you know I've been doing it for 30 years
now according to M Masashi 30 years I
should be I should be about to be
enlightened something I'm not quite sure
what that is but
anyway the that I
practice now uh everybody's different
that's why highlighted me but to me what
I get out of doing Buddha is
grunt the fight the
randomness okay the excitement the
thrill the
desperation the
emotion the
interaction gives me the grunt I look at
that
as practicing codu well that gives me
gravitas it gives me an understanding of
the the theory is you know what it is to
hold a sword how to use a sword distance
timing etc
etc uh cord is cutter
Centric of course the ones I do at least
um but always the way I look at it now
is looking for sort of like the chaos in
the order whereas Budd is competition
Centric at least the Budd that I do
and what I find myself doing is looking
for order in the chaos and these things
really complement each other hell of a
lot why the hell are we treating them as
different
things you know I I I believe and I
stand to be corrected but I believe
that's what Don DGA Sensei also thought
as well if and if we look at his
categorizations I think that becomes
abundantly clear um so in conclusion and
I'm one minute over I apologize uh
dondrea provided a succinct
categorization that is largely unknown
or ignored in Japan that's going to
change from now thank you to uh to nag
and and other Scholars um kodor versus
Bud dichotomy is ambiguous conceptual
understanding see the lump in the carpet
over there cuz it's all being swept
under all right um more meaningful
International interaction is needed I
think cultural friction is a really good
thing it really helps us put things in
perspective and again it's because of
that what n Sensei organized yesterday I
think is going to really be quite
stimulating for Japanese Scholars from
now on instead of the usual cultural
imperialism thing well we know more
about this than you guys because this is
our culture after all um it's not the
case anymore and if if anything if
you're going to do that then you're
going to shoot yourself in the foot okay
and I think people are starting to
realize that more contextual information
uh understanding is needed uh in other
words to challenge the status quo and
revisit the kind of things that Drager
uh um introduced to us I really believe
there's some incredible answers in there
more bud and cord interaction needed and
more than anything else more beer to
discuss all of this is also needed so on
that note I'm I believe we're going to
have some very vibrant discussions from
now on I'd like to thank you all and I'd
like to thank Don drer uh even though
he's not here with us I guess well um I
hope that he's here with us in spirit I
know he is inside me anyway so thank you
for your attention
everybody I'd like to point out
immediately that uh although comments
were made that Alex is not sponsored by
Nike uh he is willing to have the
conversation but not at the moment um
fantastic talk uh like any good
professor uh he's timed it so that
there's no time for any particular
questions you got it very very skillful
um said that if there's something
burning at the moment um Mike with the
mic will come around are there any
questions
now sir
mik uh thank you Dr Bennett for a very
informative and very candid uh
presentation uh you mentioned that budo
is Japan's most successful cultural
export uh and that that has many factors
some of which having to do with
government promotion um what do you
think is the most effective thing that
the central Japanese government or
bodies can do to continue to promote
budo abroad as we approach the Olympics
uh with the exception of empowering
ambassadors such as drer or
yourself I don't
know what can they do I
mean
um I mean that that's kind of a loaded
question on many different levels as
well is but I think what can the what
can they do well to give you an example
the sort of thing that I'm involved with
personally right now two things
uh whether it's good or bad I do not
know but um I I was uh asked by
Fukushima prefecture last year um to
help um try and get some interest in
Fukushima um because Japan is seeing a
tourist Boom at the moment um uh
irrespective of you know the Olympics
and so forth coming up but more tourists
in Japan than ever before but they're
avoiding places like Fukushima okay for
reasons that we well know
um and so I was asked to help out with
what they call well it's become quite a
well-known word now but Samurai tourism
and and what I did was uh it was a
monitor tour essentially but um I got a
number of interested people to come
along and we I plotted a a kind of a a
course in Fukushima that highlights the
history of Fukushima particularly the
samurai influence because last year
being 150 years after the Magi
restoration never say Magi restoration
and Fukushima by the way because they're
on the wrong
side um and tying that
history with in with actual practice and
uh the feedback that we got from the
people that that participated was was
remarkable because suddenly it all made
sense is talking about the
context okay so we're able to uh through
experience and also providing
information uh able to bring all of this
together into something that's easy easy
to understand so this was something that
I think has a lot of
potential um the other thing that I'm
involved with at the moment which so I
don't think has a lot of potential um is
thean has asked me to translate a book
uh that uh is based on a series of
Articles 24 articles written over the
last two years in the magazine get comdo
and it's about the history of karate and
if you read get Kudo you may have seen
these articles they're written by three
from
different different and of course never
the twain shall meet but it's time that
everybody got together and actually
worked out what this is because there's
no consensus in karate history in Japan
and so that's why the buom put this
together and then uh they've asked me to
translate it uh so that it can be put
out in time for the Olympics so people
were coming over here obviously they
want to see perhaps the kar competition
will also be able to see ah n this is
where it all came from sort of thing so
the the sort of things that are
happening but apart from that I really I
really couldn't give you any other
suggestions that's okay B thank you
thank
you we have time for maybe just one more
question before we move
on there's no question I'm going to ask
one what do we know about what
drer actually did in terms of Kender see
this this is something that I want to
ask um chip and and and Phil because uh
I've seen that uh drer s has nadan in
Kendall I've seen that written somewhere
um I actually uh went searching through
the archives at the zenong kendor to see
if I can find a date of conferral of
this done um I couldn't find anything
and that's not to say that it's not
there it's just there's so much stuff
that I wouldn't a wasn't able to give it
proper scrutiny so I've never seen any
video of drga Sensei actually doing
Kendall but if he does have n done
that's quite that's a significant Dar
level Phil would you would you like to
Enlighten us on
that I'm going to take a guess at
this uh I agree there I'm not I know D I
knew Don very well and I never saw him
do
Kendall however
he has a Seventh Dawn in Kendo
Federation
jodo and it's quite possible that it's
been
misunderstood so that's my answer I I'm
not posit I'm not 100% positive but I'm
pretty close to it I think I never saw
and all the time that I train with
him he never once talked about it
I I'll talk a little later when I get a
chance if that if again that comes up
okay thank you it makes a lot of sense
thank you Phil beautiful does it answer
your question turn it does thank you
very much um ladies and Gentlemen please
a round of applause to Dr Alex
[Music]